from stagnation to deflation what now
for Europe's economy in the interview
the president of the German Institute
for Economic Research Marcel fracture
mr. Fattah some experts say there's a
shadow looming over Europe the shadow of
deflation dust deflation really pose a
threat for Europe yes it does and for
two reasons one is deflation is already
a reality for many companies in Europe
if you look at the index number we have
0.5 zero-point-six percent inflation it
sounds like prices as the rising but
there there's a whole distribution
around it and what this number means is
that about one-third of the prices of
goods and services in countries like
spain italy in france are already
falling and this means for a lot of
companies in these countries and also
for more and more companies in Germany
falling prices in the onek for their own
sector for their own products is already
a reality at the same time you have to
realize we still have this positive
overall development and prices slide
rise of 0.5 0.6% but the risk of all
prices or most prices falling the index
becoming negative is rising and the
number of international organizations
estimate that this probability could be
as high as thirty or forty percent it's
not a huge probability but given that
the cost of a deflation are enormous for
the economy we should really take this
probability of having an outright
deflation but the overall index falling
very seriously and also we should
counteract the development we should
really buy insurance against such a
scenario and I think this is one of the
key challenges for Economic Policy in
Europe at the moment but falling prices
that sounds good news for consumers
isn't it
yes and no at the same time it's good
news for consumers because they can buy
certain products that can buy a sofa or
a flat-screen TV or food more cheaply
this is true but this is a very short
term perspective because if you take the
company's perspective if you're an
entrepreneur and you're producing a
particular good and you have to pay
inputs you have to pay wages today for a
product that you can produce or sell in
a years or two years time but you can
get less money for it in the future this
move mean for you as a company as an
entrepreneur that you will invest less
that you will produce less because it's
less profitable and more uncertain if
you do that you hire less people you pay
lower wages and this then means for the
consumer that there's less employment
lower wages lower income and clearly at
the end of the day having economic
growth having higher employment having
high income growth that should be more
important than giving a short and relief
to to consumers so how is the current
economic situation in the eurozone is
still very fragile yes we have a very
fragile recovery in the euro area we
have positive growth figures in most
your area countries since the end of
last year but very low at the same time
we must not forget that economies such
as Italy's or Spain's still out to date
about ten percent smaller than what they
used to be in early two thousand eight
so they have shrunk enormously and that
means we have in those economies a huge
amount of potential in the economy that
is not being used very high unemployment
rate a lot of people being with our jobs
and that shows the magnitude of the
challenge we have in a lot of European
economies at the moment and getting out
of this very deep slump having strong
growth rates that generate employment
generate income that is a key challenge
and we
we are far away from generating that
Grove at the moment now the European
Central Bank has lowered the key
interest rate to historical low was it
the right step it was a dangerous it was
a risky it was also courageous step but
ultimately I believe it was the right
decision to take it was a necessary
decision it was the right decision
because the ECB's main mandate is priced
ability and clearly the ECB is missing
its mandate at the moment by a big
margin and all the projections say it
will continue missing that projector
that that mandate for the next two three
four years so if the ECB takes is mended
seriously it has to act it has to do a
monetary policy to counteract the
deflationary pressure it was also the
right decision because the second big
challenge for the ECB is that its
monetary policy that the money gives to
banks does not reach its final purpose
namely companies and households in
particularly in southern Europe and so
the ECB is trying through by giving more
liquidity to reach those companies and
households in a better way but for that
purpose the reduction interest rates is
actually relatively unimportant because
it was a very minor step what is much
more important is the amount of credit
there is no new program the telstra
program to really try to get more money
to companies and households in southern
europe so from that perspective it's
that intention but at the same time of
course we have to be aware of the risks
the risk of that liquidity generating a
bubble in financial markets making it
much harder for consumers to save for
savers to to build up wealth and also
for a number of financial institutions
to be profitable so they are important
risks but ultimately I think it was a
necessary step for the ECB to take but
its liquidity in the market really the
problem because banks make their own
risk assessment that's not a question of
liquidity you know there's enough money
economists say
absolutely banks have a lot of money a
lot of liquidity they have been getting
from the Europeans and they don't give
it further they don't give it out yes
Dennis the the two problems is on the
one hand companies don't demand so many
loads but at the same time you also have
still a major problem with a number of
European banks in particular in the
crisis countries they still have to
reduce risk in the balance sheet they
still have to build up equity capital
they still have to find a business model
in some cases to have a sustainable
model in the long term and here is a
major challenge and this problem the ECB
will not be able to solve we really need
to tackle the banking problem in Europe
so does the ECB really has the right
tools from your point of view to solve
these kind of problems you were just
mentioning the EC we can only do its
part in solving the problem and this is
to provide as much liquidity as possible
against good collateral to banks in
order for them to pass it on but clearly
now it's really the political side that
has to act has to close down banks that
are not solvent has to recapitalize
Bangz has to really have a much stronger
consolidation of the banking sector in
Europe in particular in the crisis
countries in southern Europe so the ball
is really the court of the policy makers
of politics in Europe it's not in the
quarter of the ECB the ECB really has
done pretty much all or almost all it
can do is now the responsibility of a
political side we need to take action so
what kind of structural problems does
the eurozone still have we have a
structural problem in a lot of the
crisis countries that they need to have
a change in the structure of the economy
look at Spain which are huge real estate
sector before the crisis we need to
basically find jobs of these people who
lost their jobs in this area in other
sectors
that means crisis countries need to
develop a new economic structure need to
find sectors where they can export there
can be competitive in global markets we
need to solve a number of issues on the
European level banking is one issue we
need to have a more efficient the better
functioning banking sector in Europe
overall we need to have more
coordination on fiscal policy
government's need to stick to the rules
that is very important to regain
confidence in financial markets among
companies among households also here we
need more cooperation in a closer
coordination of policy but have you seen
any progress in these matters sue we
have seen a little progress we have seen
a bit on fiscal policy we have a two
pack a six pack if it's compact in
Europe but in my view it is too little
because if a country still doesn't want
to stick to the rules there's no way for
other Europeans to really make it
binding so we have a lack of binding
rules I believe we we need to have a
fiscal insolvency mechanism so that also
governments in the future can become
bankrupt so this is important because
financial markets then would really
discipline governments much more
strongly at the moment they don't do
that so their number of reforms that are
missing and we need to implement mm-hmm
for many people lower interest rates
means a direct financial loss so what
should people do with their money as a
general rule you should always diversify
your savings you should never put all
eggs in one basket you should always
defer to find that means you should of
course have a saving account but you
should also think of investing in small
shiny equities you should think of maybe
investing abroad because you diversify
also globally and also real estate at
least in some countries like Germany at
the moment is attractive so
diversification is the answer and
clearly you need to to think long term
in the short term equities are risky but
in the long term we know from all
studies that in
thing in equities actually is a sensible
strategy as part of an overall same
strategy now despite the low interest
rates the euro is fairly strong is that
a problem
I think it's a minor problem a lot of
European politicians make it into a big
story and say it's because of the strong
euro that our companies cannot export
and we cannot grow as an economy I think
it's an excuse I think the euros made a
scapegoat for the own failings in
policymaking in those countries clearly
the euro is probably a bit too strong at
the moment it could be five percent ten
percent weaker but the problem that we
have in many European economies is not
that the euros too strong but is that we
have a lack of structural reforms that
we don't have enough flexibility in
those economies that we don't have the
right policies right regulation right
incentives from the government side that
we have still fiscal policy that is not
sustainable so that's where the main
problems lie it's not the euro it's easy
for politicians to blame that because
they can say I have nothing to do with
it but as a general piece of advice that
we as economist should give to
policymakers is focus on those reforms
you can do focus on structural reforms
get your economy to gain competitiveness
and the euro is really the least of our
problems at the moment so lots needs to
be done thank you very much for these
insights thank you